recent memory i think of you i think of
paul heyman
as like my favorite guys to just watch
talk [ __ ] on the mic well it's funny i
stole from him right
my name is paul heyman my name is enzo
amore bro when you walk into a room
introduce yourself that's pretty much
you know standard right now
why not right how many people did that
not man i don't know i wasn't saying
would you ever come back as a manager
never not in a million years i i i
belong in the ring i'm a wrestler and
people didn't know
but i didn't care to show and i still
don't you know i still don't if you come
to my boxing gym and you're a young
wrestler like this kid casey i'll get in
the ring with you and i will show you
takedowns and show you wrist locks and
show you holds and show you shoot
[ __ ] mma and judo takedowns
that's not enzo amore enzo amore hey bro
we have chad gable out there that guy
was an olympian why the [ __ ] would my
character go out there and try to
wrestle him right my character's gonna
kick him in the nuts and [ __ ] pull a
bag over his head beat the [ __ ] out of
him yeah that's who i play
would you ever uh well has there been
any discussions of bringing you back to
wwe or any
i've heard
i've heard things um
we trended me and cass
uh in the world with these rumors uh and
it was funny because the
the blame was put on me saying oh enzo's
starting rumors about himself
and it's hilarious because i found out
down the line from
somebody in the building that it was
talked about in nxt
and uh because i probably shot down but
[ __ ] i how would i know i didn't
start what about aew
uh i mean you know i don't watch it but
i hear from everyone who's there that
are my friends that they are having the
time of their life they love working for
tony khan and that um the crowds are
incredible and the houses are good and
the fans are avid
so like i mean i'm not in this
situation where i need to get back out
there but i understand the value of
television what it does for you what it
does for your career what it would do
for my music what it would do for my
face and and my brand in general like i
get it and i need that for my mom and
dad honestly it's not even about me it's
like i got taken off a mountaintop in
the worst fashion you know but in
reality i never even got a phone call
from police bro we're talking about a
tweet you know i don't know what you
amber heard but the [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
real around here you know th this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] fugazi it's not [ __ ] so
crazy right that like uh dude
you literally get a tweet a tweet
someone tweets that you do something and
then you get fired but you're blasted on
the internet and then
i will give the people
the benefit of the doubt here
they might have said some crazy [ __ ] at
the start and i was a heal and i was a
bad guy and there were some haters but
bro 5 000 people came to see me in times
square the night i dropped the phoenix
music video wow i sold out times square
by my [ __ ] self i in that moment
realize like dawg if i don't figure this
out like
i don't need to go back to wwe that's 5
000 people in times square right now i
got to [ __ ] figure this out monetize
it something so you know i'm working on
a podcast with uh efn and nori shout out
to yeah the drink championship yep spiff
tv and the guys that drink champs are
giving uh
zoe the mic and and we're gonna do the
realest chat